the basketball chose me I come from a
basketball oriented family every single
one of my siblings play they kind of
paved the way for me it was hard to kick
me out of a jam
[Music]
I've been dedicated to basketball and
drive ever since I can remember
honestly and just being like an L a kid
my brother went to school with Brandon
Jennings he was playing against James
Harden Russell Westbrook all these LA
guys to Martirosyan guys that I watch
now I kind of got the opportunity to
look at you know from stories my dad
told me like yeah you were in that gym
and I got a chance to watch LeBron at
high school and I don't even know about
it
that's how early I did it again
this year I just think I played really
good and you know BBM myself just kind
of went along with it I think for the
most part I kind of show everybody how I
was coming basketball-wise they know
what they gonna get from me personality
wise but I think I just got a lot better
this summer and I've showed that it's
not magical or mystical there's a
blueprint on it hard work gets things
done
[Music]
yeah his work ethic is locked in and
solid because I think that he knows and
he sees what it takes to win he's been
around pros I wanted to change my mind
said I don't know reality then it kicks
in real quick you hear it all the time
like the real world and how things
change when you get older so I just
wanted to make sure I got the best shot
at making my dreams come true
looking a little froggy then I just had
a shadow faded on top that's what hey
that's what I'm doing
[Music]
well she did restore the 30th in Atlanta
yeah we play against their boy Sherif
Cooper events are gonna be super they
are they
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the things that I had to deal with in
the dark as far as basketball goes I
believe have kind of shaped me to become
another player that I am happy to take
those else and just having to sit down
and watch and not be able to play feel
like anger and you and I think kind of
shows when I play now
I think I'm able to so I am through
basketball whether it's my play or my
antics my emotions for sure the things I
wear I take pride and you know what I
put on when I step on the court I think
that's one of my favorite things to do I
think my basketball life is also
connected with music I love making
playlists and downloading new music to
get me pumped for games that plays a big
role in basketball for me you know I
cannot give myself all the credit for
anything I think there's so many people
that are involved in the success of his
life you know his older brother was
played in the league his sister which
Carter started the whole basketball
thing that he took his ales in the
backyard so he's not gonna take them in
the gym my family's young like I mean
all my coaches at Mayfair I've known for
a long time they coached my brother my
mom lives out here still my grandparents
live here still my dad is still around
to be able to finally have a school and
a place I could call home like why would
I leave I'm a Cali kid I thought just
staying in California the best state was
in my best interest you had a swag you
gonna take heat for being that flashy do
and on the court of course I'd do the
whole shorts thing not everybody you
know I think I kind of revolutionize
that but anyway I think that kid eighth
grade was more entitled I didn't work as
much think I relied more on my gifts and
my talents and basketball but I feel
like to Josh now
has earned his spot and has earned his
place to be in the room and when you say
my name you have to put winter along
with
[Music]